how have your personal relationships
been affected you know because we've
observed with higher profile people that
the people around them can sometimes
have a hard time with that success you
know however they perceive it in essence
you know they sort of feel like you know
what you you've taken my shot you know I
don't know what it is about human nature
but that you know but have you guys
experienced this in terms of before
honeymoon with my brother the
relationships that you had and then
afterward you know maybe the way that
you know people close to you perceived
you and what was happening with you guys
no I mean not not really the I would say
though not not the the book doing well
but there was definitely some you know
friends that I had before you know
taking the honeymoon that I'm not as
close with today and and conversely
others that I'm much closer to I your
priorities change and so I think you're
you're you shift towards friends with
similar priorities and I remember I used
to work at a PR firm and there was a guy
there named Mike Deaver Mike Deaver used
to be the chief of staff to Ronald
Reagan and at one time held one of the
most powerful jobs on the planet
literally and then he left and he got in
all kinds of legal trouble for lobbying
the White House he was an alcoholic he
almost lost his family his health was
failing he was being sued ease you know
being he was tried on a bunch of charges
and so he literally went from like the
highest point to the absolute lowest
point and I remember talking to him you
know years later when we were both
working for the same firm and this is
the guy I always respected and idolized
and I remember him telling me about the
importance of getting kicked on your ass
the importance of falling down and he
said you know one of the key things in
that is that you learn who's with you
and who's not with you and he said it
was so interesting to him when he went
to all his legal troubles the
the first people that called we're not
who we thought would call you know one
of the first cause he got was from Tip
O'Neill who was speaker the house and a
guy that he had you know fought against
for all of these years he's like tipa
he's like I woke up every day trying to
make tipo meals life hell and Tip
O'Neill called and said whatever you
need I'll do it for you and conversely
there was some people on his staff that
never talked to him and and fled and
didn't want anything to do with them and
he's like that's great you know that's
great because I know where I know where
I stand and I know I know who's with me
and who's not